what's up theo what's up michael this is
quincy coming at you from the great
state of texas
um my question for michael chandler
being uh just lay out for me
what your dream career in the ufc is
when a lot of guys get here
they think you know hey i want the money
fights you know and do the conor gig
or you know i just want to chase glory i
just want a legacy i want to name
you know i want to know what that
championship so just lay out what's your
ideal career with the ufc and where do
you see it going
gang gang bro yeah cause that belt's
back in play now man it is that's a good
question man because that's
it's good because it's it's like what's
what's the philosophy of
of why i'd made the decision you know
just just to give a little context
i left i left the relative uh
the relative surety of easier fights
and good money in bellator good contract
and bellator comfortability of
being the big fish little pond and being
kind of the poster boy for an
organization
to essentially come over to ufc ask to
get thrown to the sharks thrown to the
wolves right away and see what happens
um so to answer that question i think a
guy like
gaichi or tony ferguson fighting
and showing the fans who i am when when
that fight
fight the way exactly the way that i
fight prove to the fans okay this guy's
here to stay this guy's a legit
contender for the lightweight belt
and then fight for the belt whether it's
habib or whether it's
conor poirier whether it's whether i'm
the number one contender
after beating one of those guys and then
connor poirier is the number one
contender
we fight for the title sometime middle
of 2021 and then
uh and then after that just defend the
belt and get the big fights because i
think
and a crown they should put a crown on
you guys man crown would be cool
you know or like a metal you know like
like an olympic gold medal you know yeah
crown would be crown would be cool
but keep going sorry oh no but then
you'll get a crown hopefully
and then uh and then defend the belt a
few times defend the belt a few times
and then for me
i don't say get the big fights just for
the money but you get the big fights
because that's how you get the attention
you know it's like
it's like the gary vee uh approach of
capturing as much attention as possible
if you don't have people's attention or
you can't get people's attention they
can't
they won't pay attention to you and they
won't you know
life is all about who knows you who
trusts you
and then who's going to to buy what
you're selling not just
money-wise not just buying products but
buy what you're selling like
what kind of motivation are you selling
people what kind of
character are you selling people what
kind of what kind of theos are you are
you
selling to the people so that you can
reach the masses and for me it's all
about
touching as many people as i possibly
can through this platform that i've been
given
touching every walk of life every corner
of the globe hopefully
and uh so winning the world title
and then getting big fights either
defending the belt or you know
bmf belt or the big you know the big
fights with the big name guys to get as
much attention
and eyeballs on me not for the you know
not for the ego of it but for the
platform of it
yeah that platform yeah that's a good
point you know once people know you then
you can do stuff with it
yeah i mean that's and that's really
what it is because it's it's a catch-22
and it's like oh
he just did that for attention and it's
like yeah as long as you don't ever
sacrifice your morals or your character
it's okay to do things for attention
you know like i came over to the ufc
essentially for attention you know i
came over to the ufc for
competition competition and attention
those are two things that i get from the
ufc that i'm that i couldn't
not that i wasn't getting at bellator
but i get more in the ufc
so it's okay to want more attention
especially if you've done things to earn
it you know
was there a time previously that you
were going to come to the ufc and it
didn't work out or was there how long
did this
i mean how long is this whole convo
going on is it one of those ongoing
conversations for like a decade what is
it like
so it's one of tho it's one of those
deals where i never actually became a
free agent there was some reports out
there that chandler's a free agent he's
you know
he's gonna you know but i ever actually
you know two years ago and four years
ago
was on the last fight on my contract
ended up re-signing with bellator with
the one
fight left on my contract so i was never
a free agent until
august of of uh 2020. and uh
it just seemed like the right time this
time back then
because it's also it also depended on
what the ufc lightweight division looked
like too
you know two years ago the landscape
looked a lot different you had habiba's
the champion
you had conor off doing 100 million
dollar fights with floyd mayweather
he could come back leapfrog me whenever
you had poirier
coming in you one or one of those guys
had an interim title two years ago he
was either tony or
it wasn't pourier because i think pojo
was after that but maybe it was tony
i think tony had an interim title habib
had the title
habib wasn't coming back necessarily so
it was just a weird time
it was a weird time for me to come in
now it
exactly what we thought now it's perfect
two years later i'm coming in at this
time which couldn't have been even more
so
two years ago and i said this to dana
when i spoke to him i said listen two
years ago
four years ago i wouldn't have been the
guy that you needed to be to come in and
be the champion and be the superstar of
this division and i truly believe that
i'm going to be that i don't say that in
a cocky i don't say that in a cocky way
i just believe like i want
you gotta believe it i just believe that
that's that's what's going to happen and
and maybe there's gonna be people that
laugh at me i fall flat on my face and
that's fine but at least i find out you
know
that's how i feel in my heart right now
and you can't you can't knock a man for
how he feels in his heart you know a man
who hitches his dream to a star
that's the only way you can go out and
create create impact in your life and do
amazing things so
that's what i'm doing and man it's been
uh it's been cool but i never became a
free agent until
just this year and it just never seemed
like the right time to become a free
agent until this year
damn good evening good afternoon and
other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah